[Music]
this has been the best christmas with
you guys let's make christmas eve dinner
our tradition i think i speak for our
family when i say we are in everyone say
pumpkin cheesecake
in the town of north pole we know how to
do christmas and for me and my best
friend
there is no competition you're attrition
diana the unstoppable duo who wins the
home decorating contest every christmas
diana is a yin to my name but when the
whole season is about going over the top
i have held this title for 10 years i'm
not letting someone else take it from me
now i just feel like you're always
pushing me what is that supposed to mean
it's not always about winning it's easy
to go too far oh my god
please tell me you got that
oh btw we're no longer in speaking terms
with the riveras if our moms break up
they're gonna be on us even more i've
got an idea hey
guys we're here
look at all of us like the good old days
you are so not winning that golden
reindeer this year who's gonna stop me i
am i have to show diana that i could win
without her
a supermodel snow woman is that my
swimsuit so good
men and women hanging out after eight on
a weekend is a date well we should wrap
this up fast then it's hard because
she's always been there for me we were a
team our moms will kill us do not bring
up our phone
she just got pegged by santa
[Music]
mrs logan i really need that reindeer oh
i'm sorry this is for my granddaughter
this is logan where is your holy spirit
this town is ruthless
[Music]
you